and a new interview president Trump says
he would take information offered by a
foreign government about a political
opponent a statement that brought
immediate criticism from Democrats of
course Paula Reid is at the White House
Paula what could this mean with top
intelligence officials already warning
of interference in 2020 and the
president now saying he'd listen well
good morning Tony this appears to be an
invitation to interfere the president
has repeatedly insisted there was no
cooperation between his campaign and
Russia during the 2016 election but in
this interview he suggests he might be
willing to work with a foreign
government to gain a competitive edge
and this directly contradicts guidance
from his own FBI director I've seen a
lot of things over in my life I don't
think in my whole life I've ever called
the FBI in my whole life I don't you
don't call the FBI President Trump says
he wouldn't necessarily alert the FBI if
foreign governments offered him dirt on
a political opponent I think maybe you
do both I think you might want to listen
I don't there's nothing wrong with
listening when pressed on whether he
would want that kind of interference in
US elections the president disputed the
term interference it is a crime for a
campaign to knowingly accept anything of
value from a foreign national a poll
shows voters from both parties
overwhelmingly support a law requiring
campaigns report contacts with foreign
governments to the FBI this is somebody
that said we have information on your
opponent oh let me call the FBI
give me a break but FBI director
Christopher Rae has urged exactly that
if any public official or member of any
campaign is contacted by any nation
state or anybody acting on behalf of a
nation state about influencing or
interfering with our election and that's
something that the FBI would want to
know about the FBI director is wrong
there's a hike in an exclusive interview
with Dan Crawford last month even the
president's Attorney General said the
administration needs to act against
foreign powers trying to interfere how's
the Justice Department working now to
ensure this doesn't happen again in 2020
we do have a I think a increasingly
robust program
that is focusing on foreign influence in
our election process the president's
challengers for the 2020 election said
his comments are further evidence that
it's time for n't hearings we have a
president who neither understands the
Constitution of the United States or
respects the Constitution he is yet
again open to the idea of working with
foreign governments to undermine the
integrity of our election system it's
outrageous
the president's remarks come as his son
Donald Trump jr. faced additional
questions from lawmakers about the Trump
Tower meeting where he and other
campaign officials met with a Russian
lawyer who had offered dirt on Hillary
Clinton but the special counsel found
that meeting did not amount to collusion
because the officials didn't know the
law and never got their dirt Tony while
the president's former aide hope Hicks
has also agreed to testify what can we
expect from that well this would be
significant Tony because this is the
first former administration aide to
testify in the committee's investigation
into whether the president tried to
interfere in the special counsels
investigation but we won't actually get
to see this hearing it'll happen behind
closed doors eventually they will
release a transcript but it's unclear
how much they'll actually be for us to
see because the president has asserted
executive privilege over so many of
these events she may not actually have
to answer many questions
all right Paula read for us at the White
House Paula thank you very much